bonjour à tous le bitcoin est un sujet
qui intéresse énormément il a un côté
très intéressant et un côté un peu plus
obscurs et justement aujourd'hui on va
s'intéresser au côté obscur côté obscur
de la force
savoir si le bitcoin est toujours en
refuge pour la cybercriminalité
on va regarder ça maintenant
le bitcoin c'est un sujet qui fait
couler beaucoup d'encre il est créée
depuis moins de dix ans il participe
vraiment une révolution
la création de la blog shane alors là
blocs shy'm j'ai pas vous expliquer ce
que c'est il ya des gens qui le font
très bien
d'ailleurs je vous invite à découvrir
une chaîne qui le fait super bien qu'ils
s'appellent h heure je vous ai mis un
lien dans la description pour ma part
juste vous parler aujourd'hui du côté
négatif du côté noir de l'agglo chase et
du bitcoin parce que le bitcoin
effectivement c'est une crypto monnaie
il en existe beaucoup d'autres autant
ses cryptes aux monnaies sont super
intéressante parce qu'elle ouvre de
nouveaux horizons
autant effectivement elles ont vraiment
des côtés très négatif
pourquoi est-ce que bitcoin intéresse
énormément tout simplement parce qu'il
permet d'avoir très rapidement en retour
sur investissement il est monté à plus
de 16000 euros là tout de suite alors à
la question de la vidéo il est un petit
peu moins de 8000 euros
il évolue énormément en fonction de
l'offre et la demande en 2017 il a eu
une ascension qui complètement dingue
il intéresse de plus en plus de monde
alors effectivement il ya plein de
kryptonite existe on parle beaucoup des
bitcoins parce que c'est un petit peu la
star des crypto monnaie alors pourquoi
est-ce que c'est crypto monnaies ont du
succès premièrement elles ne sont pas du
tout contrôlée par une autorité centrale
elle dépend comme je le disais
uniquement de l'offre et de la demande
deuxièmement elles sont faciles à mettre
en place
troisièmement elles sont surtout anonyme
quatrièmement c'est extrêmement
transparent toutes les transactions sont
écrites dans un espèce de grand livre
général qui s'appelle la bloque chain
cinquièmement les frais de transaction
sont minimes
sixièmement c'est rapide pour les
transactions et 7 seulement ces noms
duplicable dès lors vous avons envoyé un
bitcoin vous pouvez pas récupérer quel
est le problème avec ces crypto monnaie
le problème des crypto monnaie c'est
qu'elle sert de passerelle entre
l'économie légale et l'économie
souterraine canalisations l'anonymat des
transactions comme vous êtes anonyme
il est complètement impossible de
remonter jusqu'à vous elle permet de
contourner tous les dispositifs de
contrôle et de sanction financière
internationale en gros il ya aucune
régulation et aucune traçabilité
c'est complètement anonyme retour sur
investissement rapide anonymat
transaction facile faible coût ça
forcément attiré très rapidement la
cybercriminalité et la criminalité en
règle générale d'ailleurs dans les faits
le bitcoin est en règle générale les
cryptes monnaies sont le moyen de
paiement préféré
des cybercriminels j'ai pas si le terme
de rançon nous r ça vous parle je sais
pas si mona cry ça vous dit quelque
chose
si vous faites une recherche sur google
vous intéresser à tout ce qui a commencé
il ya quelques années
ce système de rançon ou erp ou quelqu'un
vous bloque votre ordinateur et vous
demandent une rançon de 300 $ en bide
cogne pour que vous puissiez réutiliser
votre machine est un espèce de cryptage
si vous voulez de votre bécane
elle est complètement bloqué vous pouvez
strictement rien en faire et le pirate
en face vous permet effectivement vous
dit je veux bien vous le déverrouiller
vous le débloquer ça me coûtait 300 $ en
bitcoin lui récupère l'argent il n'est
pas possible de tracer et vous vous êtes
fait dépouiller de 300 dollars au
premier trimestre 2016 ça aurait
rapporté plus de 209 millions de dollars
ou pirates selon le fbi avait donc voyez
le business sur un trimestre juste sur
du grand sont ouverts c'est énorme
alors les beach boys les crypto moderne
également autre chose vous pouvez
acheter sur le darknet des armes de la
drogue
vous pouvez également vendre des numéros
de cartes bleues des informations
confidentielles vous auriez récupérer il
ya un vrai business qui se fait là
dessus et tous payants bitcoin
l'écriteau monnaie sert également à
blanchir de l'argent à financer le
terrorisme a permet de vendre des
informations provenant de piratage
massif choses qui arrivent à yahoo ya
quelques années nulle + 3 milliard de
comptes et yahoo qui ont été piratés et
qui ont été revendus et payé en beach
boys alors ça c'est un vrai problème si
vous voulez on voit qu'il ya un vrai
effet pervers d'un côté vous avez un
vrai succès populaire parce qu'il ya une
vraie révolution qui se fait du côté de
la blog shane non pas du bitcoin parce
que le bitcoin n'ai jamais pu monnaies
parmi tant d'autres même si
effectivement c'est la première
historiquement si elle qui fait parler
le plus d'elle mais ce qui est vraiment
intéressant en arrière c'est le système
c'est là blog shane donc il ya vraiment
quelque chose de révolutionnaire quelque
chose qui va changer notre rapport à la
monnaie dans les années à venir
mais pour l'instant il ya un vrai effet
pervers et le problème en plus dans tout
ça c'est que le fait que les
cybercriminels et accès très rapidement
des moyens de paiement ça va permettre
d'augmenter leur nombre parce que c'est
effectivement un attrait financier c'est
comme tous les business dès lors qu'il
est compliqué de monétiser son business
de récupérer l'argent à se faire payer
les business n'existe pas ou distrait
peut dès lors vous avez en face des
moyens de paiement vous avez une
économie même si effectivement si
l'économie souterraine libye
ds peuvent être prospère et ça c'est
effectivement le cas de la
cybercriminalité grâce aux cryptes
monnaie voilà ça c'est positif on est
très content d'avoir parlé de ça mais
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer dans
les faits alors normalement il devrait y
avoir des évolutions l'union européenne
pour exiger des plateformes sur
lesquelles ce sont les transactions qui
est un peu plus de contrôles alors
effectivement ça reste toujours très
compliqué mais dès lors qu'il aurait des
opérations qui pourraient être
suspicieuse les plateformes pour y
regarder davantage les utilisateurs
éveillé un peu aux opérations suspectes
alors ça peut paraître effectivement
compliqué de se dire qu'est ce qui
définit une opération suspecte mais
imaginons par exemple que vous ayez un
seul compte qu'ils reçoivent des
milliers de bitcoin qui arrivent de tous
les côtés
ces cas par exemple dans son annuaire
vous allez avoir un mec qui va bloquer
énormément de machines dans le monde qui
va recevoir beaucoup d'argent et
toujours même montant on va pouvoir se
demander si effectivement lui n'a pas
une pratique malhonnête
l'idée globale c'est d'avoir un
encadrement de la bloque chain d'avoir
un encadrement des crypto monnaies
simplement pour qu'il est sa vraie
fonction première c'est à dire servir
aux consommateurs comme un moyen de
paiement alternatif aux monnaies qui
sont ils plus couramment connu comme le
dollar l'euro le yen je vous en passe
encore énormément
l'idée c'est effectivement de rendre la
crypto monnaie le bitcoin et tous les
autres - salle en tout cas beaucoup plus
clean alors effectivement il ya un autre
problème avec le bitcoin c'est que
maintenant que le bitcoin est une valeur
de dingue alors fait même si
effectivement et c'est un petit peu
cassé la gueule puisque le bitcoin a une
énorme valeur des gens qui se sont fait
braquer leurs bitcoin est braquée
numériquement et des plateformes qui se
sont fait voler pour plusieurs millions
de dollars mais il ya des gens qui sont
fait voler directement avec des vols à
main armée il ya un trader par exemple
qui a vu arriver chez lui des personnes
mal intentionnées qui ont ligoté sa
famille et qu'ils l'ont forcé à
transférer ses bitcoin dans leurs
portefeuilles a eu comme quelque chose
d'anonymes
on peut pas savoir à qui profite le
crime donc on voit effectivement que les
crypto monnaie la bloque ça y est c'est
quelque chose de passionnant il ya un
vrai effet pervers arrière l'intérêt de
tout ça si vous voulez dans les années à
venir dans les mois à venir même ça va
être deux
encadrer davantage non pas pour que les
états se l'approprient et qu'ils en
fassent leur nouvelle monnaie puisque ça
irait vraiment à l'encontre même de la
crypto monnaie et de l'agglo jane mais
par contre qui un vrai encadrement pour
que les cryptes monnaie ne servent pas
enrichir les cybercriminels voile un peu
pour suggère c'est vrai que l'âge
laborde
de ce point de vue là il y aurait
énormément de choses à dire vous allez
voir on va en reparler un peu dans les
temps à venir par le biais des crypto
monnaie on parle également technologie
de telle manière avec des monnaies
dématérialisée il ya de l'enrichissement
qui se crée comment est-ce que ces
modèles fonctionnent d'un point de vue
matériel afin là il ya énormément de
choses à dire dessus
donc je pense qu'on en reparlera dans
l'est dans les temps revient d'ailleurs
je vous invite si ça vous intéresse et
si vous vous intéressez à l'univers de
la tech en règle générale à vous abonner
pas soyez par toujours plus de choses
très intéressantes
je vous remercie bien évidemment d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo je vous invite comme
d'habitude à me laisser des jolies
pousse à rester connectés parce qu'il ya
plein plein plein de choses qui vont
arriver dans les temps à venir d'ici là
portez vous bien
soyez sage je vous embrasse comme l'avs
et à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]